you're gonna tell me that this is a good
chicken
i've eaten it like i said yeah this is
crazy you can't not go to the store and
buy stuff and resell it
cannot are you aware of what you're
doing
do you actually care
yes you do care
which part of this hotel would you care
every park
this is how delusional you are that this
is a good chicken
what's in this one here
stop that weed
pre-cook yes yes what's that
eggplant
so everything's just reheated the
microwave
yes we're in danger i've been shut down
by the health authorities
i'm sorry folks
basically i take responsibility
i'm sorry
i'm very ashamed and
i am fed up from not being hurt it
doesn't matter what i say karen is going
to do what she want to do
[Music]
what's going on core diamonds i don't
have no help man i told her she won't
listen
you can't perform like this i can't i
can i can only i can't you can't just if
you're gonna get [ __ ] arrested i
won't get arrested put in jail for
killing some damn body
ah
gordon this is the worst restaurant i
ever worked in in my life practices are
the problem right
the sort of
the way that everyone's walking around
in denial there you are but
but there's no standards though you're
not maintaining a level that
they deserve yeah i know that i know
that [ __ ] so why have you become like a
zombie and following her emotions i'm
not i'm trying to figure have you given
up no i have not given up i have not
given up you're just as bad as she is if
you don't put your foot down and say no
i tell her no no no no no no no and she
keeps on doing it
someone needs to draw a line i have
drawn the line
it doesn't matter
i can only do so much gordon this is not
my place
uh my apologies ladies and gentlemen i'm
so sorry sorry what a joke
have you seen any of this stuff going on
here do you have any idea what's going
on
what's this
pre-cooked bacon pre-cooked from when
it's dated they they do it every day
just about right no they don't
when was that cooked
that's not today if they did
honestly let's see what it says 10 31.
we're in november the 6th now
this is insane
look at that in there
don't you drain that or
it just sits there in his blood
and in here that's a freezer
what is that
[Music]
what's that noise that's the fan
what a nightmare
now karen you've got no idea that this
is going on like this
what is that in there there's dish water
no there's french fries in there fries
why is the water so dirty
nobody didn't change it sorry nobody
didn't change it sir
but you're cooking fries from there
tonight in that water
i saw them fill up the fryer twice
it sucks
where'd you get the ham from
she bought it at the store holy crap
it's a spiral cup they cut it and put it
in here
and then uh use it for
side of hand for breakfast
when was last time this was clean
ah last year when i cleaned this shelf
last year when we cleaned the oven we're
in november
last year yes sir
i asked karen i said okay we need to
shut down somebody we gotta we gotta do
maintenance
look at the mess
why have you let it go like this
i didn't know that they were doing
things that were not here no but listen
to me jeff this stuff bullshitting the
guy okay let's tell him the truth here
okay i asked for some new equipment
i can't get no new equipment why not
i've been here for four years i've been
asking for new equipment
i can't work with this [ __ ] here look
look at that
[ __ ] piss
i've been asking for the ass with new
equipment how long do you think this
shit's gonna last ain't gonna last
forever
i'm just so [ __ ] fed up with every
damn thing
i can't get no help
me and jill pulled you out of this
and now i asked for some help with some
equipment that you can't spend
that noise is working
and that's working look at this [ __ ]
look at this
of the damn line
i'm just so [ __ ] fed up with every
damn thing look at this [ __ ] look at
this
heard of the damn line
you can't expect to work in this
are you greedy with the money i'm in
debt i'm barely breaking even
let's get real
they're out there with sand they're done
they're finished and they're spent for
us
i've been cooking for 20 years and i
never had this problem
we have to step up
i mean look at the kitchen
it's atrocious look at this here would
you work in this i do
um so funny with you no it's not bad
look at the mess can't do it
you own this place but i delegated the
restaurant to them
and then the bottom line is you have no
idea how to run a restaurant and all
you're doing now is blaming the staff no
i'm just they're taking the heat and
your problems aren't their problems but
they become their problems because look
at the mess
you don't even think there's a problem
that's what worries me
practices are so bad that's what i try
to say
why is it got this bad you have to take
responsibility you're ignorant oblivious
and delusional
i'll do what i can do
it's not good enough
i'm going to my room
i've seen enough [ __ ] for one night oh
man
thank god somebody else sees it but
other than us this is what we deal with
on every day it's nothing my damn hat
it's in there i'll find it i know where
you threw it you know we could have done
this without ramsay
i mean anybody can no not with their
i don't have
what do i spend on myself now i'm doing
the best i can i borrowed money and went
out and bought more refrigerators then
oh we need freezers i know i care i'm
not uh why don't why didn't we just tone
down the menu the menu is what you all
do you could have told me that these are
the things we need to do
i will tell you jeff i have no stake in
that menu i thought that's what you and
jill wanted no that's not there
until you get your way you work hard i
agree i understand over the years you
have averaged 44 hours a week
and you're paid for
i'm listening jeff
you're not hearing me karen
what a mess i mean one of the worst
dates of a kitchen hotel in i've ever
seen in my entire career also a owner
that is delusional and she's convinced
herself that the place is run properly
and you know i'm really uneasy about
just being in here
the smell is appalling everything feels
dirty and just
and i'm not convinced that even the
bathrooms
are that clean i'll run a quick test
quick bacteria test there's a communal
bathroom that i am uncertain about when
this thing reads 30 it indicates that
it's a sort of
um
a decent
level of hygiene basically it's clean
anything over 30 then it gets into the
danger zone
this is where the smell is really bad in
here there's crap everywhere it's just
so unhygienic
to get a good reading
grab the swap underneath the mat
the smell
under here is appalling
in these crevices
there's dirt
that's gross
that's gross
that is disgusting
snap it let the liquid go down give that
a shake
in
holy crap
no
i'm unconvinced that this place is clean
everything smells it's very difficult
for you to identify the smell but in
here it really stinks
so
just
it's just the smell from here stains
everywhere and what scares me is the
fact that the kitchen
took a year to get cleaned
god knows but this time so pretty gross
now pop that in there
i'm not sure when this place was cleaned
properly
in
oh my god
karen is karen in here
karen
just go upstairs please two seconds
please let's go quick
come in
i've just done a swab test
with the carpet i told her the smell is
gross
anything above 30 you're in the danger
zone for unhygienic practices and it's
not fit for customers what do you think
the reading is a hundred a hundred
fifty fifty
sixty seventy seventy
eight hundred and three
[Music]
eight hundred and three
oh my god
oops
803
oops bernie that's not the boobs that's
okay oh no
103. wow
this is just the carpet
you can't be that bad we get a lot of
bikers
bicyclists and hikers you're paying 130
to get out of bed and step on
a disgusting
stinking carpet
it smells like there's crap all over the
floor probably because there's crap on
the floor
probably could be
what does that mean could be
my first
shift here you were in the bathroom and
i think you had an accident on the floor
on the mat
i mean yeah there have been times when i
have had diarrhea but it doesn't happen
very often
no i didn't realize that there was that
problem
[Music]
all day both of you have been in denial
not one of you told me about the
problems not one of you taking any form
of responsibility you're happy to serve
that food to me lunch time you're happy
to mosey around and piss around on the
walls and paint silly pictures
this is a travesty this is shocking
your staff knows it but you two are
oblivious
but the rest of the room is
dusted and clean
it's not he's not he's not talking about
the room it's not about the rug it's not
about the food it's about the whole
picture look at the cage you're yelling
am i not allowed to yell sarah because
someone has to because you're not he's
trying here to help us stop being in
denial it's not about the rug and this
perfectly dusted thing that this is not
gonna make a difference the whole
picture the whole thing
what are you scared of karen admitting
well i'm working 16 hours a day and
spending every time
these are rooms too that i get positive
feedback about oh my god i'm serious a
lot of there you go again
no you can't be that no no i i i want to
fix things i am not sleeping
in this dump
i'm done
i'm out of here
oh man
you can't leave i'm not staying in here
ramsay
don't go
[Music]
karen this is a travesty that you're
paying 130
to get out of bed and step on a
disgusting stinking carpet you're in the
danger zone for unhygienic practices and
it's not fit for customers we get a lot
of bikers
bicyclist and hikers what are you scared
of karen admitting
well i'm working 16 hours a day without
your excuse you fall back on that these
are rooms too that i get positive
feedback about oh my god i'm serious
there you go again no you can't be that
no no i i i want to fix things i am not
sleeping
in this dump
i'm done
i'm out of here
oh man
he can't leave
ramsay
don't go
i'm not staying in here
is this your office in here
that's my living quarters in my office
i live there you live in here yeah
let me show you
what i saw the office sign
on the door but you live in here right
here
this is my bed
i just uh sleep here
like this
are you
kidding me
every night you sleep in here yes
is there a mattress there no it's just
quilts cover on them cheats
you sleep on a board
in the winter i could go upstairs but i
choose not to i choose to stay here i
wish bathroom views and shower i use the
ones upstairs
what's the room next door oh that's the
beverage area and then beyond that's the
kitchen the beverage area
the keg is right on the kegerator it's
right on the other side there and then
that's the beverage
right there oh my god
so
i sort of sleep in the kitchen
this is crazy
i love it here there's no place in the
world i would rather be you're not doing
one thing right
you have lost it completely and you've
convinced yourself
in amongst the chaotic mess that you
live in
that it's all right it's not it's absurd
this is no way for a lady to sleep and
live and eat
you shouldn't be living in the kitchen
there's not even a fan or an
air-conditioned room it's a tiny cubby
hole yeah
cluttered with your junk
are you okay
i think so i mean this is not normal
what's normal in what's normal
seriously
i can't even start to think about
helping you
when you're in such denial
[Music]
the next morning i woke up not wanting
to give up on the town's ear seeing how
bad the kitchen was and learning that it
wasn't clean for over a year
i hired a professional cleaning crew
to not only declutter
but to scrub down the kitchen as well
[Music]
crap everywhere
good morning
ah morning than about being good so well
could be better could be worse yes um so
we were you sleeping ah i was i've got a
headache i don't know why
i don't know since i've arrived
i'm still unconvinced where i'm going
with you and this business however i
want you to do something all right
something you haven't done properly in a
long time
and take that yes
and start packing
ah
i'm not messing around i haven't got
time to mess around okay but we're
don't worry about that i just want you
to start packing up
quickly
i've got enough boxes
[Music]
and
little things this is yeah i do 9 time
is of the essence i need you to start
packing and i'm starting
start packing
quickly
i'm worried about karen not listening to
me and i don't think she realizes just
how bad the business really is
i reached out to her son jason the
majority owner of the inn who has the
most to lose if karen fails to turn it
around jason how are you i'm doing well
thanks yourself yeah very well thank you
townsend
take a seat
uh so what a beautiful place yeah i mean
it really is gorgeous yeah i fall in
love with this area uh beyond belief um
unfortunately i haven't fallen in love
with the inn
i'm shocked at the
setup and what's happening to your mum
currently yeah do you have any idea how
bad it is i think i have a sense but
obviously i'm out here on a daily
regular basis so i don't appreciate the
in an ounce of it she's in denial i'm
trying to explain things to her
in a very calm way and she's just
refusing
point blank to understand the logic i
think her her vision has been both her
blessing and her curse in the sense of
it's what's allowed her to drive through
this and persevere but it's also what
puts her in denial have you seen where
she sleeps
yeah
does that make you feel happy not at all
not at all i mean we bought this with
two main motivations to let her develop
this end business but also have it as
grandma's house and it's not we went
into this
looking at it as as obviously we want it
to be some type of investment but we
didn't have a particular game plan
beyond just rent out the space to mom
and we want to see it do well not just
to make money but so that she really can
have a life here it's just been triage
since day one that's no way to live no
does this become a burden on your family
now or yes it has it's because we're
concerned for for her
it
it's a financial burden this lady wasn't
your mother and she was renting from
your property you'd be a lot more severe
in the way that place has been handled
we all bought this in part with with our
hearts and not just our heads and it's
that balance between wanting to respect
her desires to to make this business
what she wants it to be but also realize
that if it's not going to be a
profitable business and if there's going
to be a cost not just financially but
physically and emotionally we need to we
need to shut it down now this is your
mum you know it's not a cousin or niece
or a nephew this is your mum so um she
needs to hear that
it's affecting you personally
financially it could drag your family
down you're not her safety net
i need you to have a word with her and
how we're not prepared to move forward
unless she's going to commit to change
and i'm talking long-term change
she needs help and she needs help
urgently
[Music]
oh my i think i overloaded this one
after spending time this morning with
karen's son
we both agree in order for the business
to succeed he needs to confront his mum
that a major change needs to happen
well karen um first of all um i spent
this morning catching up with jason okay
good and just trying to get him up to
speed with what i've been discovering
you know i'm not happy
and i think deep down inside that you
can't be happy
in this current existence
so
i want you to listen to jason
as you know we've been talking a lot
about what's going on here why we're
here what we want with the business
you're my mom but you're also my my
tenant and so i have two main goals and
objectives with this place and uh one is
is a financial one
for your sake for my sake for our
family's sake and then my second
objective is to
encourage and support you and your life
you're not just an innkeeper you're my
mom you're you're a grandma and for us
to enjoy all those things we have to i
think make some changes here it's not
sustainable financially emotionally and
and physically
i just don't see the business in such a
negative light as you do
i i look at my women you realize most
people do yeah
i
i look out my window and there's the
potomac river in the train station you
can't see out the wind am i dying oh i
can't it's above it
uh okay but
even even the bags of clothes yesterday
and now the boxes of clutter
people don't live like this
you you you have to get out of there and
you have to start
living your life completely different to
what you've been doing i'm not here for
three months can i'm here for a short
time to give you everything i've got to
get this place fixed
and if you can't listen to jason and
you're not prepared to listen to me i'm
not asking you all we're all working for
the same goal here i'm listening i'm
telling you it needs to stop
for your sake for my sake for our
family's sake i can't keep renting the
house out to you if we can't get a
business that is consistently profitable
the place is in jeopardy and there's not
one element functioning properly and
your business
is going to take jason's family down
if you don't sort this out
[Music]
um
i don't want to burden my children at
all
so that
that is something that is high priority
for me
but you have to come to terms with
yourself that it's broken it's wrong and
you have to change
and i'm willing whatever you propose
i'll try otherwise
it's game over
let's move forward
i am agreeing to help i'm gonna put a
plan in place but
uh
you can't continue the way you're doing
it you know that
thank you jason thank you thank you
do you know what his plan is i have an
idea
[Music]
after karen packed up her belongings i
had my team start the renovation process
while i found a place close by for karen
to move into
hi karen are you well yeah i'm very well
thank you good let's step inside
something i'd like to uh all right show
you
come in please
it's got a lovely place do you like it i
do what do you like about it um
well it's not cluttered it's not clotted
is it yes i like that
when i saw where you've been living for
the last
12 months
i was appalled
you shouldn't be
going to bed
on a piece of wood
i know you shouldn't be doing that
if we're going to make a
change then you have to step back
and i mean step back from the business
and that means giving yourself some
space
so i've
done something
and i'm paying for it out of my own
pocket and
i've rented
this space for you
for the next couple of months two months
two months okay two months great give
yourself a break
you can relax
watch a bit of tv i haven't had a
television since 1993.
so this is really a big change yeah so
since 1993. even if you're not going to
watch tv
read oh relax i can do it i'm just
taking the view
and if you decide to move back in there
and you convert one of the rooms and
it's got an ensuite bathroom that's all
fair and well but then
you need to separate the difference
not in a box
i like this i feel comfortable here have
a look upstairs there's a beautiful
bedroom there and a full-size bed all
right
there's a
ensuite bathroom and nice a wardrobe to
yourself big bathroom
very nice
i could go to sleep right now
wake me up in two hours
we've got work to do
okay
[Music]
all right
[Music]
that that was comfortable um karen you
need to
you need to start thinking about
being a boss being an owner with that
comes certain responsibilities what was
it like for you to be an owner what's
the importance
well the important thing was serving the
guest
and trying to nurture a good
relationship with my employees right
that means setting an example yes yes
and being the face of the end yes right
what do you think is the most important
thing about being the face of a business
having a presence yes standing out like
an owner okay you need to walk this
historic town looking like an innkeeper
polished
now i feel bad about asking a lady to
glamorize herself so i'm not trying to
be detrimental it's just okay i'm gonna
send you
off
for a makeover
okay when was the last time you went and
had a facial got your hair done and
bought a new dress with a a bright color
i don't think i've done that since i was
13 years old
where's last time you went for a
blow-dry
never
i mean i i
have a blow dryer but i i never go to a
salon right where's the last time you
had your nails done never mm-hmm
never correct
that was never a priority for me but
you're you're
but we're gonna make something here
we're gonna make it a priority because
it's about you
it's a business you have to front it and
that that comes with an image yeah
i'm glad you're up for a change i want
you to feel better i want you to enjoy
your life i want you to appreciate what
your team can do for you
and hopefully just break them all a
little bit 100 you're happy with this
i'm
ready to enjoy it
thank you so much i have a security
deposit here so it's a rental no murals
all right we'll leave it the way we
found it thank you see you shortly all
the best here you want me to turn on the
tv for you or not not yet
i'm gonna take this one step at a time
youtube
um i've seen a few things on youtube
yeah
instagram
never but my granddaughter is teaching
me a selfie taking a picture of myself
oh never huh tinda
i don't even know what that is
welcome to the dark ages
this was one of the toughest makeovers
my team has ever taken on we had not
only moved karen out of the towns in but
packed up all her clutter before
transforming the space good morning how
are you feeling
excited
the sun is shining there seems to be a
new bright breath of fresh air on the
town's inn
we're missing somebody here we are
she's been busy over the last 24 hours
i'm hoping you notice a change
oh my gosh
oh she looks beautiful
i don't even dress like this to go to
church
now somebody's looking like an owner of
an inn yes you look amazing for someone
with an amish midnight lifestyle
probably i look radically different
you look amazing she looks so different
karen you look good yeah really good are
you ready to go inside i've been
dreaming at this moment right um follow
me let's go
come on all of you
oh my god
[Applause]
[Applause]
a tiny little convenience store that is
bright and modern and everything is on
view and even if you're not staying in
the inn guests will come in and buy
stuff you can sell stuff properly it's a
proper little boutique
oh overwhelm um
it looks amazing
amazing
what gordon has done is phenomenal the
story here looks great it's like walking
into a whole nother place please
whoa
god is the dust
oh my goodness
well done
beautiful design beautiful when i walked
in this dining room first off it was
dreary and laden with junk and now we
have a proper dining room yes
oh lovely look at the all-day menu the
menu that hangs on the wall is written
daily according to what you've got
available jeffrey yes and when we run
out we run out we tear it off and we
start again if you turn around you'll
see the custom artwork on the wall
please do not paint over that i will not
i will promise you no no
i love it that's the only mural we need
on the wall just that and that is enough
yeah right you ready to see upstairs
yeah
as you come up have a little look at the
hallway first please
oh wow
gone are the baskets anyone wants to do
a little bit of work a little bit
writing consistently totally beautiful
wow jump in everything's going just
jumping oh my gosh
new sheets new bedding and a new carpet
it's beautiful
oh
wow oh my god no more murals on the wall
we have a nice stunning wall i love it
no more brillo pads in the wall they've
gone
i love it and you have your very own
wardrobe
no pair box on it
how nice is that yes you can use a
wardrobe it is exquisite
my family thinks i'm so set in my ways
that i'm not gonna like any of these
changes and i'm gonna go right back to
the old way i know that's what they're
thinking and they couldn't be further
from the truth
[Music]
my team has spent the last two days
cleaning out the kitchen by getting rid
of the microwaves refrigerators and
freezers
[Music]
i've created a much smaller menu that is
manageable for the kitchen staff to
execute
please take your menu and pass them on
what do you think
could it be more beautiful and appealing
isn't it
now let's be real the kitchen is tiny so
a small dynamic menu as the seasons
change we go through to spring and some
of them will increase on a daily special
only according to what business
is about that
and so we're not buying unnecessary and
we're not adding 10 more appetizers and
entrees on there just because we want to
look busy no keep it plain and simple
keep it plain delicious and simple let's
go through the dishes a high street
burger no water
no water
uh beautiful pate wonderfully seasoned a
griddle in there to sear and cook them
to order
chicken pot pie
little modern twist on a salad nicoise
but we've done it with salmon homemade
granola
seasonal berries cheap and easy to put
out that tiny kitchen and then of course
the mac and cheese it does not go in the
microwave where's that
what's that the sports bar of microwaves
is gone
um visually what do you think it's
beautiful simple oh and fast and it
takes a big load off in the kitchen yes
and we're not buying frozen it's all
fresh
right knife and fall and have a little
taste oh man
that is good oh my god that's like
mama's name macaroni and cheese people
will drive from washington dc to come
here
and eat this way so good
tonight the town's inn relaunches the
inn and the restaurant right how are you
feeling good are you ready yeah yeah
yeah absolutely tough week but it's been
instrumental let's put this place back
on the map okay push the freshness to
the menu i don't want anybody panicking
there's nothing we can't do on the menu
any issues we talk about it if we talk
to each other we prevent mistakes
happening if we shut down things will
happen without us knowing karen i think
you'd like to say to the scene thank you
and i'm looking forward to moving
forward there you go
good luck let's go guys
let me help you down the stairs thank
you good to see you welcome to the town
center look at that you checking in it
looks like immediately the guests see
the changes in the dining room and the
rooms
yeah it's beautiful yeah wow look at
this
very nice i love this bed this is pretty
nice oh look at this get a nice armoire
and throw our stuff in here how do you
like the changes looks good
i can definitely say this is way better
like that this is definitely an
improvement yeah
that's a burger with french fries vlt
and a mac and cheese great the kitchen
is functioning more efficiently with a
smaller menu and is preparing the dishes
cooked to order and karen is overseeing
the inn as an owner and successfully
treating this place like a business for
the first time how's everything so far i
heard you like this
order please yes i got five minutes on
the burger shop and we got two orders of
fries all right nice and crispy the
fries and seasoned beautifully yes yes
sarah chef
well done
that is outstanding
so now we have a place to come in the
winter time good thing we come back yeah
we're locals what does it mean a small
little local bistro to the town how good
is that for you actually it's huge uh we
need more local bistros like this we're
really excited to have it
that's good to see it's okay good night
thank you guys
happy customers wow
[Music]
i'm off
thank you man you're welcome don't lose
that passion
yeah continue enhancing this kitchen and
stick together yes you're strong
together you too yeah okay okay
take care
right see you soon look after each other
okay
tonight proved that this place can work
the potential is incredible the locals
are dying to see this place at the
forefront of this amazing town the area
is historic
make sure you're in
follows down that line karen i know
change is gonna be hard i know you're
gonna resist
but you cannot afford to go back you've
got to go forward i know how much this
means to you and i know what kind of
jeopardy is at stake if it doesn't work
so think are the consequences it's not
just you
it's your son your son's family and the
legacy that you want to continue with so
i'm leaving you all the tools push
forward
promise me you're not gonna go back to
your ways no no this is more fun and
more effective and i just have seen the
positive response from everybody you you
did the the groundwork here thank you so
thank you i've been amazing in yeah okay
amazing location
move those clothes back in from a
loman's basement get rid of this stuff
let it fly off the shelves and start
getting this place back on the map and
enjoy that lovely little cottage take
time out and spend time with the
grandkids and just let the business
breathe
yes
i promise yes thank you
all right
gordon's visit has been extremely
educational
this is good this is right this is what
it should be
thank you
i want them to be successful and i think
it will be now take care now
thanks karen good night
wow that's it that's it
wait come back
come back
[Music]
since my visit karen has continued to
lease the house i had previously rented
for her and has been listening to her
staff to make positive changes that is
awesome and her son jason has gotten
involved with the business to help karen
meet their goals and both are happy to
report business is heading in the right
direction
[Music]